[Musique]
bienvenue à poissy nous sommes dans ce
parc meissonnier magnifiques espaces
verts de la ville de poissy et je suis
devant c'est ce joyau architectural qui
s'appelle la maison de fer qui était
construite à la fin du 19e siècle et qui
ressuscite aujourd'hui quitte en vie
grâce à vous car le leem
vous êtes le maire de poissy bonjour
bonjour patrice carmouze c'est un projet
que vous avez porté
évidemment comme maire de poissy mais
vous avez bien avant oui en fait c'est
tout part en 2008 en 2008 d'abord
rappelé que je suis né voit ici aux
prises avec une famille nombreuse on
était huit et cher patrice quand on
était gamins on visitait cette maison
qui s'appelait à l'époque la maison
effet cette maison heffel était niché
sur les autres voici nos lois étaient
pas ici on n'est pas ici non loin d'un
quartier populaire
en face de l'hôpital à deux pas des
futurs de la future caserne de pompiers
aujourd'hui et on allait se balader dans
cette maison de fer avec les copains on
joue à achat on jouait à cache cache etc
c'était un moment de détente et c'est
vrai que la tempête de 1999
vous l'avez rappelé cher patrice a été a
balayé cet édifice et en 2008 je me suis
rendu compte que et bien en fait avec le
ministère de la culture nous disait vous
allez pouvoir la plage et la mer ont
fermé la lettre vous avez donc et que
ses jours étaient comptés au
conservateur régional des monuments
historiques d'île de france
il vous dit cet édifice est sur le point
de faire l'objet d'une procédure de
radiation de la liste des monuments
protégés au titre des monuments
historiques
c'est la fin quoi oui et je le comprends
vous montrerez peut-être des images
elle est l'image des soeurs grecs c'est
une ride c'est une urine il ya quasiment
plus tôt l'on va pas grand chose
les arbres ont envahi ont envahi
l'espace et là on se dit deux choses
soit on laisse passer effectivement le
tracteur le bulldozer et c'est facile
germaine que personne ne se rend compte
à l'époque sur ou alors on essaie de
sauver le patrimoine et c'est pas facile
et c'est ce à quoi en équipe
seul on va plus vite ensemble on va plus
loin on a décidé effectivement de
relever le défi en équipe c'est quoi
d'abord c'est une association demi
huit coeurs de poissy et puis ensuite en
2011 c'est l'association des amis de la
maison de faire c'est un architecte qui
vient bénévolement parce qu'ils croient
projet un architecte qui vient que sa
petite mallette son crayon de papier ça
gomme pour faire des relevés
topographiques
c'est un de mes proches rémy l'euro qui
est aujourd'hui directeur des affaires
culturelles de la ville de poissy qui
est très engagée et qui est passionné de
patrimoine qui petit à petit au moment
de 2014 puisque entre 2008 et 2014
il s'est pas passé grand chose on a
beaucoup commentaire est lui encore en
revanche quand je suis élu ça a été le
premier vous la ville premier combat
clet'che midrand projet culturel encore
une fois un mot ce projet parce que sous
l'impulsion évidemment des élus mais
derrière la mise en partition d'agents
qui sont exceptionnelles parce que je
crois on y reviendra à la valorisation
des équipes des équipes en interne
alors on a déposé un permis de
construire pour démolir un permis de
construire pour démolir parce que
l'endroit où était restée russie elle
dormait n'appartenez pas d'ailleurs à la
ville d'art tenait là et sapn donc au
ministère des transports
ensuite on a fait un permis de
construire pour retrouver un endroit où
lemaitre et si vous êtes dans un écrin
exceptionnel
vous l'avez dit c'est là la ssii c'est
le pack mais ça y est c'est oui c'est au
fond la ligne g dire patrimoniale de
poissy c'est exactement cela
le parquet saulnier qui appartient à la
ville de poissy qui est protégé et donc
inscrits et on est au coeur du futur
circuit architecturales et patrimoniales
la maison de faire c'est pas par hasard
qu'on a trouvé cet endroit en descendent
un petit peu vous allez vers la gare et
vous allez tomber évidemment sur la
collégiale
mais en passant il ya le circuit
piétonnier de delaby avec l'historique
musée du jouet la porterie salle oui et
puis en remontant ici à quelques cents
mètres à vol d'oiseau on à la ville à
savoir de la fameuse villa savoye de le
corbusier un script patrice vous le
savez au patrimoine de l'humanité depuis
le 16 juillet 2016 et là on est on est
vraiment le coeur patrick exactement
d'heure et si je continue un tout petit
peu plus après parce que l'idée c'est de
contribuer à écrire l'histoire
la création du musée unique le corbusier
au monde avec les amis de le corbusier
avec le centre des monuments nationaux
et on sauve actuellement on travaille
dessus
la léproserie historique de la ville de
possibles une lacune en ile-de-france
avec la maladrerie la chapelle de la
majorité qui se situera à deux pas du
centre d'entraînement du paris saint
germain
voilà donc on continue de tirer
l'histoire une histoire on écrit
l'histoire c'est le futur se nourrit de
l'histoire exactement et moi j'aime à
dire que il faut être acteur de sa ville
et pas spectateur de celle des autres
c'était important pour nous de sauver ce
patrimoine est de montrer au pis y'a
kenzo pisciacais dans un premier temps
qu'ils avaient raison d'abord de vivre à
poissy et pourquoi on était fiers de
notre élevé saint louis bien sûr alors
évidemment reconstruire à l'identique
alors on il ya en effet un mélange de
pièces qui sont des pièces d'origine et
puis des choses qui ont été recréés mais
c'est un coût évidemment ça a été un
budget de plus de 3 millions d'euros
oui c'est trois millions cinq cent mille
euros de reconstruction alors on dit
bien patricia à l'identique mais aux
normes d'aujourd'hui on ne vous avez un
acheteur kaboré personnes à mobilité
réduite
vous avez des aménagements extérieurs
que vous voyez vous voyez on a c'était
une des exigences que j'avais auprès de
mes équipes conserver 30 % des pièces
d'origine qui était dans un escalier
grâce à l'état l'escalier date de 1896
typiquement et les tôles exactement les
taux longs
on va peut-être on va peut-être pouvoir
les voir système de tôle emboutie
système de tôle emboutie patrie c'est
pas compliqué à comprendre
c'est exactement de la même manière
qu'eux sont construites les voitures
c'est les ailes de voitures les portes
de voitures avaient apprécié on apprécie
on connaît bien à l'atelier
d'emboutissage par exemple tad les
ateliers de compression et vous voyez
sur c'est sur ces plaques
on le voit bien ici vous avez des
plaques avec un tout petit peu de peau
d'orange
eh bien c'est exactement
donc voilà on a on à la fois cet édifice
à nul autre pareil c'est un des joyaux
du génie français est important de
sauver aussi le génie français
moi j'étais amoureux on a travaillé
ensemble à canal+ patrice est un secret
pour personne
on produisait des films notamment sur
elle notamment
on est des amoureux de
beaucoup des mots parce que vous disiez
on appelait ça la maison heffel quand
vous étiez petits cp on n'a pas tout à
fait raison de dire que c'est une maison
heffel n'est pas faite par eiffel était
faite par monsieur qui s'appelait joseph
dans l'eee exactement joseph dans l'île
qui a mis en place ce système de de tôle
de tôle emboutie pourquoi on appelait sa
maison est faible parce qu inspire et
inspiré et elle date quasiment de
l'exposition universelle
exactement et puis dans l'eee eiffel
eiffel se connaissaient jeu on peut
penser qu'elle fait là et fait même une
peut-être une commande auprès de joseph
dans l'île pour pouvoir construire cet
édifice
il ya cet édifice patrice évidemment
mais il ya tous les aménagements
extérieurs
bien sûr pour la grande majorité fait
par la ville j'insiste c'est important
pour moi que chacun s approprie c'est
vous me posez une question tout à
l'heure sur le financement ont parlé de
trois millions cinq cent alors y ait une
poêle au dollar devant les événements à
hauteur de deux millions cinq cent mille
pour financer en partie le circuit
architectural la région la région ile de
france et lui du mécénat privé
exactement on a décidé de créer un fonds
de dotation qui est unique en ile de
france s'appelle mais seine aval mais
seine aval
et puis scène on est à côté de la scène
qui est en fait un fonds de dotation qui
permet au privé patrice carmouze aux
entités morales une collectivité la
ville le département la région d'abonder
au financement et en plus d'avoir des
réductions fiscales
c'est un contrat gagnant gagnant
quelques cents et ça a très bien
fonctionné
des privés au 1050 euros 1000 euros 3000
euros avec 15000 euros
des banques ont également abordé là
encore une fois on voit bien en train
qu'il ya une appétence et puis une
volonté de sauver le patrimoine français
ça on l'a vu pour notre dame mais on le
voit pour ici quoi patrice ça montre
aussi que des personnes qui croient
rives c'est pas la flagornerie vous
croyez aussi à ça comme stéphane bern
que vous connaissez bien ça montre qu'on
est capable je dirais non seulement de
sauver mais de pérenniser le patrimoine
français et la culture est très
importante
évidemment quand on réalise qu'on relève
un défi tels que le défi de
reconstruction la maison de faire c'est
formidable c'est formidable pour les
contemporains
je pense aussi aux futures générations
il faut qu'on laisse à nos futures
générations
ce que nos anciennes générations
naîtra ce qu'elles nous ont laissé 12
enseignants pour savoir où en est
exactement mais dit un peu l'intérieur
sur bien sûr avec grand plaisir et avec
avec bonheur patrice bienvenue dans sept
ans cette maison faire mais vous voyez
l'architecturé particulière qui est créé
je vous propose de tout de suite
emprunter cette espèce y aller quand
même de faire qu'un examen pour
découvrir le musée de cette maison de
faire parce que cela devient dangereux
on explique l'histoire exactement en
prison de fer exposition permanente une
au premier étage ce sont des expositions
éphémères éphémère et on commence par
une très belle une très belle exposition
vous allez voir bienvenue dans l'univers
de mécano et c'est quand c'est pas la
cdu faire des galops c'est dû faire un
petit peu notre tour eiffel à dos ah oui
donc il ya un buste avait fait et puis
on a plein de lille bruxelles eiffel et
puis regardez c'est la magie il ya d
autres faire la maison de faire un
croyais à l'échelle 1 12e qui a été fait
par les amis de les amis de mes cadeaux
et qui nous ont en quelque sorte fait
cette offrande pour l'inauguration de la
maison de faire c'est exceptionnel comme
se gêner ce génie de l'époque quand on
voit comment est constitué de faster et
dc le très beau de voir ça parce qu'on
se rend compte aussi de ce qui à mon
sens de ce qui était cette architecture
est aussi très cartésien et très c'est
très disciplinés 1
c'est la discipline de l'époque passer
l'aide si oui c'est la fin du xviiie
siècle exactement c'est la révolution
industrielle
voilà c'est aussi toute cette période
l'accès des rubis grâce à cet essai des
baux clin d'oeil à notre beau pays
voyez alors on a cette exposition
éphémère et puis voilà on se jette sur
ce havre de paix patrice avec une vue
tout simplement exceptionnel incroyable
vu la vallée seine et puis ici avec la
possibilité d'organiser des visites
privées évidemment on a un jumelage
parle par exemple avec nos amis
allemands de pierre mas 1 c'est nos amis
russe de kaluga
je nous vois bien ici organisé ces
jumelages organisait aussi avec les
chefs d'entreprise c'est l'économie les
chefs d'entreprise ici venir venir
dîner passer du temps oui c'est
important que chacun s'approprie seront
créés j'en veux dire une matière vivante
ça c'est aussi important d'être dans le
mouvement parce que le mouvement
rassemble vous savez ça c'est l'humain
justement quand on est maire comme ça
d'une ville comme quoi si évidemment il
ya il ya l'économie c'est très important
les entreprises c'est très important et
le patrimoine aussi mais le lien entre
les deux l'un ne va pas contre l'autre
quoi oui puis il faut surtout pas il
faut surtout pas opposer la culture à
l'économie le patrimoine à des données
financières 1 euro 1 euro dépensé pas
très c'est pas un euro dépensé san euros
investis investi la culture ce n'est pas
une dépense c'est un investissement
et je crois que c'est important d'en
prendre conscience sinon tout fout le
camp et par les temps qui courent
pardonnez-moi mais notre société a
besoin de s'appuyer sur des fondations
solides
la maison de faire le génie français est
un élément solide et je donnerai
constituant de notre de notre beau pays
pour les très fier voilà d'avoir un
bravo parce que voilà c'est un peu une
oeuvre de longue haleine exactement ça
commençait on le disait en 2008 bien
avant que vous soyez mer et voilà vous
avez le résultat aujourd'hui dans les
yeux et je pense que les habitants de
possibles tous les habitants d'île de
france est ravi de venir ici
eh bien on les liens étranges et puis on
espère que nos amis japonais qui
viennent visiter la villa savoye
s'arrêteront sur la maison de faire
merci de votre venue patrie merci
infiniment karl olive
[Musique]